welcome to Table Talk where each week I
unpack insights from Christian theology
and spirituality that help you become a
more thoughtful calm and just a
wonderful human being my name is Brett
Tilford
and today I want to talk to you about
one more connection I see between an
insight from the book black box thinking
by Matthew syad and our emotional
spiritual life so if you're interested
in a bit broader introduction to science
book you can find that in a previous
episode I did a title to fail your way
to success so here's the other big idea
from science book that I do and it's
this iteration rather than a master plan
is almost always the wisest way forward
so so what is saiad me - well we're
always going for the big change the
massive overhaul the sweeping reform
that will change everything
when the reality is that we're better
off as science says tinkering tweaking
and learning from practical mistakes for
example perhaps your grades are
currently a mess and so you go ahead and
you read a book or you watch a video or
you hear an inspiring talk and then what
do you tell yourself you say I'm gonna
change everything and so you spend a
week making a master plan of all the
changes you're gonna do like I'm gonna
change like when you study and how you
study and who you study with and you
know on and on and on and you launch out
and either a you get completely
overwhelmed with all the changes or B
you execute the plan only to realize huh
well most maybe all of these things
didn't really work the way I imagined
they would and of course studying right
this is just one example it could be
anything from growing your department at
work to improving your marriage or your
prayer life we're all tempted by the the
seductive call of the master plan
the big thing that will fix all our
problems and saiad he actually gives a
really insightful story of this from the
business world it's in the form of a
narrative about the company Unilever
and a problem they faced in making
detergent so basically the process is
they would boil together a bunch of
chemicals in a vat and they force that
brew through a nozzle at incredibly high
pressure and speed and out the other end
came a vapor and a powder the vapor was
siphoned away the powder that's what we
know as long as like a detergent
granular detergent so here's the problem
the problem is that the nozzle it just
didn't work smoothly it was constantly
getting blocked they had to shut down
production because the the size of the
grains coming out which is very
inconsistent this led in efficiencies it
cost them a boatload of money and so
they turned to a team of really bright
mathematicians and engineers and these
were they were experts in like high
pressure systems and fluid dynamics and
they said innovate us a new nozzle and
so they did they delve deeper and deeper
into the problem and they studied it
from like every possible angle and they
drew up sophisticated equations and they
eventually came out with a new design
and guess what didn't work so in
desperation you can only return to a
team of biologists these biologists knew
like nothing about fluid dynamics but
they did have an understanding of
evolution and the concept of tinkering
and iteration and so here's what they
did they took 10 copies of the nozzle as
it currently stood and they applied a
small change like a different kind of
change but a small one to change to each
one and then they tested them and of
course one of them outperform the others
just a smidge and then they took that
winning nozzle and they did it again
they made 10 versions of that winning
nozzle made a slight change
and retested and so they did this over
and over and over they it took them 45
generations of nozzles 449 failures but
at the end of the process their nozzle
was freakin awesome and what's
interesting is that of course like they
they couldn't have known this from the
beginning like they had no master plan
but what they did was follow a simple
formula of test a test B choose the one
that did a little better and then make
another test and this is of course what
we call iteration so coming back to our
lives because of courses and I'm table
talk about detergent I think the reason
we don't opt for this strategy is that
we fear it will take too long and we're
discouraged by the small progress I mean
here who says my goal this week is to
get 2% better like who tweets that who
puts out on social media like your your
annual goals you know by year-end goals
like I want to be 2% better like no but
just imagine here's the thing if your
marriage was 2% better this week than
last week and then you did that again
and again and again or what if your
department at work was 2% better these
come in two weeks as opposed to the
previous students or your connection to
God 2% better right but too often we're
unsatisfied with 2% and we want to shoot
for 50 percent better like today and
it's called the lure of the radical
innovation though one change that
changes it all like we love the quick
fix don't we but so often the master
plan doesn't pan out and we're stuck
with zero percent better or perhaps
slightly worse so today don't despise
small beginnings test something out try
it
tweak it track your progress and see if
you can get just 2% better that's all
for a day if you enjoyed this content
please click the like button comment
below if you know someone who could
benefit from it share it and to ensure
you don't miss any future episodes you
can go on YouTube or any pod
outlet in search bretzel for Table Talk
have a good one
grace in peace